hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to turmoil now this game is
about what you would think it's about
getting oil out of the ground it's a
resource management game and it just
came out recently from early access so
I'm gonna start a new campaign because I
have no idea how to play oh it could be
Blanche Daisy
Ricardo or Joshua mmm I'm feeling
Blanche I like it hello there just being
a lawyer sound interesting no not at all
get a serious case of oil fever and the
only gear is more cowbell delighted to
make your acquaintance I'm bored already
Daisy
buenos dias I've sailed the world nope
howdy partner this dude has been herding
cattle long enough to know that Knights
on the Prairie are cold and lonely I
think I need to know about that Joshua
but I appreciate the flirtations I'll
start with Joshua here why not hi there
future oil baron welcome not soon to be
a little bit above that basics of oil
drilling okay let's dig how do i oh
click the wagon on the right to start
you got it hop on it'll take you to the
thank you chill thank you very much
where are we going oh ok welcome to your
first oil mining operation just follow
my instructions in the oil will be
flowing in no time but where you can
start drilling for all you have to know
where to drill hire a dowser to take
care of this
Oh God with a stick a guy with a stick
is gonna wander around and hope for oil
someday how in the hell do you explain
that one dum dee dum ya dum dee dum is
right oh you found oil it's time to
start drilling select the oil rig hope
well drag downwards from this point
release the other point to connect to
the oil but how do I know where it is oh
maybe maybe baby well we're gonna find
it that's actually pretty cool the way
it geometrically fractures the ground oh
oh baby the guy with the stick knew what
he was doing
hello Joshua go be lonely on the Prairie
no more who the are you you struck
oil but where should you take it to left
ink of course select the horse wagon
icon ok place a wagon here and it'll
automatically collect oil and unload
that my company or do I get out of this
it don't seem like a lots going on for
me all right whatever then you know what
I'm gonna put complain about too much so
long as I'm making money with oil then I
can sell it and destroy the environment
as much as I like yeah I was back in the
old western days when nobody cared this
introduction ends when you brought the
cash amount back up to $1,300 okay hey I
get the basics of it I ain't gonna wait
for that I got I got time on my mind
it's okay
good job now time for the real work come
to the town hall to meet your rivals and
get your parcel land for your next
venture my ravel movie people are gonna
try to take my claim oh that was gold
that wasn't oil am I talking about
hello I was expecting you yes maybe
because you just told me to stop by
again ready for a partial land let's
take a look at the map okay
oh no howdy partner this dude has been I
think I think I know who that is
oh I'm not you oh you really were
flirting with me oh okay oh no wait that
is me wait a minute I'm very confused
about this am i me or you me I'm not me
nobody else is me but me I'm the only me
that ever means me y'all shut up
good day to celebrate the opening of my
brand-new Bank I've opened up an account
for each of you you can also visit me up
to view a financial report of your last
venture Nick money's great okay
loan loan me all oh my god how about how
about no seasons hey you know what fine
let's do this I can take it I can handle
crippling debt that's what normal
Americans do we get in debt up to our
knees and then hope for the best okay so
let's get that oil we're taking $2,000
with us to cover the costs are you ready
to go
I sure AM bye everybody let's get my guy
with a stick out there and ready to rock
a silo to store the old did he just
sniff the ground I mean I guess I would
help more than anything he seems to have
an idea in that one spot but boo
baby give me the oil buddy come on buddy
give me the oil please any minute now
I'm crushing your fat head with this
okay I'm assuming that means you found
no yes
what are you done buddy do something
about it okay there we go finally Jesus
how am I supposed to know all right
whatever I hope for the best
maybe maybe not but maybe you will maybe
it won't where did I come from where to
go weird ball my oil go holy bow I
don't know
ah there we go that's the stuff it's so
silo Candide wagons wagons go get it
yeah oh wait what's the point of us wait
a minute he coulda just taking it to the
incorporation why did I need a silo that
seems like totally a mess damn it
alright you find another one over there
cuz I ain't gonna be dealing with all
this stuff well what is that gonna do
that's not gonna do me any good because
I'm not gonna be able to do what I need
to do what you sell my goddamn oil what
is this number
well they didn't tutorial ëismí enough
oh I should have paid attention in
school that's sister that's just another
thought but you know I was just
wondering ah there we go okay they're
selling for some reason oh hey thanks
buddy
alright hopefully you're right I don't
know but hopefully huh uh huh huh huh
huh so we need a lot more wagons Winston
seems oh just barely in there almost not
quite
okay I've spent all of my money if I
spend all my money on employees and
workers and equipment then there's no
way my business can fail there's no such
thing is too big to fail in markiplier
world I think I need another one wink
thing any two more
yeah just load down with everything
Noorie I got the world's greatest high
interest loan from the bank nothing
could possibly go wrong to me I put all
my money in beanie babies and
Teletubbies there's no
way it'll fail also oil will boil what
if I can just dig around what if I to
send these tubes of flooding I think I
think because the price I think okay
here's what I think the strategy is with
the silo you store it until the price
gets bigger and then you have everyone
flood the market with your oil so that
you can get the most money out of it
but until then you just need to store it
which is mega primo good Ariel go for it
go everybody go go go
price go down hurry the hell up what are
you doing why are you going to the right
stores over there and left incorporated
we don't have a right incorporated yet
it's not being such dicks whatever I got
a lot of money that's good whoa whoa
what's happening oh god it's the
apocalypse
oh no end of the world shits going down
and what the hell happened
Oh God oh my crippling bank debt has
ruined me oh hi Dan I've made so many
poor choices
I should have pudding shouldn't put all
my investments in Enron ah dude
okay anyway Wow I I have sucked up a
storm I it seems like everybody lost
money not another I'm moving on though
howdy my name is Fred Mel are you
looking to make your own mind operating
more vision under my factory to upgrade
your you all right I don't know if I can
expand I don't know if I can afford any
of that
Brynna nut good oh yes I was expecting
oh geez land auction okay already mind
open for bids um
pick a parcel and numbers on mine parcel
indicates how much oil they had well I
still got I still got oil and that one
maybe I could maybe here you do that
here's where the oil is okay
all right then all right thank you
I got land now let's go back outside
goodbye everybody
I'm gonna go dig we got this unlock this
time oh I see
levels were run from January 1st to June
30th oh that's handy all right looking
for another place to sell your all come
to me and my prey price is always right
I get you and I'm gonna have to dowsers
looking for things first cuz I want to
have start this operation gingka what
you doing over here go lay down bubble
go lay down I gotta finish this out I
gotta make my money with my oil my oil
riches go lay down lay down you know
where to be you know you're not in the
right place
I said go lay down huh I gotta be I
gotta be firm oh ok right by left
incorporated well that's gonna make
things awfully easy for me ok I did it
we do the thing okay I'm not gonna have
any silo this time because why not broad
should have a side with ya I'm not gonna
have a silo this time silos are stupid
ok so now that I got my supply train
over enthusiastic about things I should
be able to do what I need to do to make
things done so where's that guy gonna go
well that guy's just gonna why is that
guy just looping back and forth oh I
need actually sir
over there I need to make some money so
bad I might as well dump it oh god the
price of oil horrible that's not that
bad this is why need a silo yeah okay I
got it I understand now I understand I
understand okay now stop that put the
silo right cool
I should have put that silo in the
middle Shania that would have been a
much more strategic solution to what I
was doing but then again I'm not very
bright when it comes to business matters
is gonna need to go deeper on it huh
wait is that gonna I don't know if
that's oh what is that doing it's
flowing in the wrong direction
I I goofed I think I done goofed very
hard
oh wow these prices are dismal oh these
prices are bad
oh man is just all I gotta make money
somehow
oh it's climbing back up I can wait we
got till June we can wait it out baby
maybe not but we can wait something out
I don't know if it's gonna be good
enough oh god it's getting full in there
all right start shipping over ship it
out right go go yeah we're doing pretty
good in the price has been going up for
a while it might just start to go down
on the right side there and it's going
on the left but I think my main problem
is I've got an exorbitant amount of oil
sitting in that silo over there for no
particular reason it's just literally
just sitting in there oh I gotta switch
it up let's go left side let's go left
let's go left left left left left go go
go go it's much better and closer to the
silo because I illogically place that
much like every other decisions I've
ever made my life I don't know what I'm
doing
haha every oil tycoon knows you fake it
until you make it and then you break it
and we'll buy it I mean the earth in
half to get that sweet delicious oh yeah
so far so goo and
aigoo I mean oil anything else that
rhymes with GU but I'm getting a lot of
Mines lose I hope so I mean things are
going particularly well this time I well
over my profit margin than I had before
not par Finbar best prairie fur furfrou
Gege I'm making money and that's all
that matters I mean there's almost no
point and even keeping it in the silo
because the price goes up and down all
over the place anyway so I might as well
just dump it to some butter I mean
there's got to be like a strategy like a
document that you can see like one
versus the other as far as how strategic
it is for you to go like build it up all
on the left side and make it quicker to
go there so that no matter what the
price is because it's gonna take travel
time to go over to the right and it is
way overthinking this but I'm just
trying to mend maxis because I'm a pro
gamer and super sick at my skills and
and I'm like doing some Naruto
ninjutsu stuff but I'm also making money
from oil and this one's almost this
one's completely out of oil
big dick randomly diggin random
directions
hopefully it'll work for you if not the
room are you still getting oil where are
you getting whale from are you getting
oil from the dirt is that that oil sands
thing that you just squeeze it out of it
squeeze the sole out of it now that's a
bus big take it a random-ass direction
Oh scoop it around I don't know if
that's gonna help me at all
Rembrandt's limit reads bullsh oh I was
so close
oh no what Oh who's got it
who's got oil baby what's got oil huh no
way
Oh God end of the world bureaus above I
got it I got all I got oil baby but I
probably spent way too much money making
that but I did it so there we go ha ha
hey I am Timo's profitable you guys are
sack dung I am the best
alright what else you got goodbye I'm
gonna do this one more time with AH with
I like more girth for my oil
what do you got damps hmm scanner I
don't know about that I can't afford it
I'm actually gonna build another one
right dear and then hop Pinsky I said ha
penske oh god I don't have enough money
do I so little right so little
right oh god I need more give me more
give me fuel give me fire give me that
which I desire Oh woah girthy what does
that mean there another one buy it so
you're trying to tell me boo
boink I'm hoping you better be right
about this if you're not right I'm gonna
be very upset more what goons their
equilibria s-- Oh No sorry to be better
for the left side no wow where's mobile
gonzo there it is stop stop stop it
stop it I say stop oh damn it yeah we're
gonna we're gonna Gerta size this we're
gonna Gerson ate it ah we just ran
dry
what'd I do the runs dry that doesn't
help me there's a load of crap
I just Garza nated those lines are you
telling me I didn't need the girth
innate them side of a well
that
what's it Oh
how's I supposed to know this dowser
didn't know anything because he couldn't
dig deep enough what a douche all okay
so that's probably all that I'm gonna
play for this game I'm obviously not
gonna put it into a series but it is a
lot of fun I like these resource
management games you can find this one
on Steam so thank you again and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye gonna like that
you seem happy for little fits in bursts
at a time the rest is kind of about